>>> WELCOME BACK TO HOUR-LONG
PREGAME SHOW AND IT IS ZIPPING
RIGHT ALONG, ISN'T IT?
>> YEAH.
>> AND ALREADY 20 MINUTES DEEP.
>> THE PLAYOFFS ARE DEEP, AND I
AM READY FOR THE WEEKEND TO
START.
INDIANA AND WASHINGTON COMING
YOUR WAY HERE ON TNT.
AND WE WANT TO TAKE SOME TIME TO
LET YOU KNOW WHO THE ARE
FINALISTS FOR ALL OF THE REGULAR
SEASON AWARDS.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> IN THE NBA, AND WE WILL START
WITH THE MVP.
THE THREE FINALISTS ARE BASED ON
THE VOTING SO THAT YOUR THREE
TOP THREE POTENTIAL MVPs IN NO
PARTICULAR ORDER THERE ARE STEPH
CURRY, JOEL EMBIID AND NIKOLA
JOKIC.
WHAT YOU THINK, SHAQ?
>> WELL, BASED ON THESE GUYS'
RULES, WHICH I DON'T THINK THAT
IT SHOULD BE THAT, I AM GOING
WITH STEPH CURRY, BECAUSE KENNY
HAS SAID IT, HE IS THE BEST
PLAYER ON THE PLANET, AND
ACCORDING TO THE RULES AND THAT,
AND MY QUESTION TO THE PANEL, IN
THE ALL-STAR GAME, AND THE
ALL-STAR MVP AND WHY DID HE GET
THAT?
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, ONE TIME,
THEY HAVE -- HAVE THEY EVER
GIVEN IT TO THE LOSER?
>> BECAUSE THE TEAM WON, BUT
BECAUSE THE BEST PLAYER OF HOW
HE PLAYED, AND THE INDIVIDUAL
PLAY.
AND THE FINALS MVP AND THE OTHER
TEAM WON, BUT THE GUY IS
DOMINATING THE FINALS, AND
THE --
>> BUT THEY ARE WINNING, FOOL.
>> BUT PLAYER.
>> WAIT, DID YOU JUST WIN ALL OF
THE WINNERS!
>> CHUCK, LISTEN TO WHAT I AM
SAYING.
>> YOU SAID THE WINNER, AND THEY
PICKED THE BEST PLAYER ON THE
WINNING TEAM.
>> BUT THEY SAY THAT THE PLAYER
IS THE MOST VALUABLE PLAYER, AND
A LOT OF GUYS PLAY GOOD ON THE
BAD TEAM, AND GUYS THAT PLAY
BETTER ON THE WINNING TEAM, AND
THAT IS WHY THEY WIN.
>> WHAT ARE YOU SAYING?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN WHAT AM I
SAYING.
>> THE GUY ON THE BEST TEAM WINS
MVP AND YOU JUST SAID THAT --
>> NO, I SAID THAT THE ALL-STAR
GAME.
>> YES.
>> WHEN THE GUY WINS.
>> AND THE BEST PLAYER GETS THE
MVP.
>> YES.
>> OKAY.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE THEY WON.
>> BECAUSE HE IS THE BEST
PLAYER.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THAT YOU
WON?
BECAUSE HE IS THE BEST PLAYER.
BEST PLAYER.
>> THEY STILL WON.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> I GET WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS,
SHAQ.
>> BUT STEPH CURRY IS THE BEST
PLAYER IN THE LEAGUE, AND I
DON'T CARE ABOUT THE RECORD.
>> AND STEPH CURRY IS IN THE
PLAY-IN GAME.
>> AND HE IS STILL THE BEST
PLAYER IN THE LEAGUE.
>> AND TOP THREE, AND IF --
>> STILL THE BEST PLAYER IN THE
LEAGUE.
STOP IT.
>> TWO GUYS THAT I WOULD LOVED
TO HAVE SEEN IN THE TOP THREE
POSSIBLY TAKING ONE OF THE
SPOTS, AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE OR
HOW OR WHAT BUT THAT IS DONOVAN
MITCHELL HAD PLAYED THE WHOLE
SEASON, BECAUSE THE TYPE OF
SEASON OF WHAT HE WAS DOING, AND
HOW HE PUT THAT CONFIDENCE IN
THE BATTERY OF THE PACK --
>> BUT HE IS NOT PLAYING LIKE
STEPH.
SO STOP IT.
>> AND STEPH CURRY, AND I SAID
IT EARLIER.
AND HE IS THE BADDEST MAN ON THE
PLANET WITHOUT QUESTION.
>> STOP IT.
>> AND HOWEVER, THERE IS A
CHANCE, SHAQ, THAT THE GUY MIGHT
NOT MAKE THE PLAYOFFS.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THAT CAN
CONSTITUTE MVP OF THE LEAGUE.
>> WHY NOT?
BECAUSE IF HE DOES NOT MAKE THE
PLAYOFFS --
>> NO, NO, NO.
>> THE IMPORTANCE OF THE --
>> WELL, THE MOST VALUABLE
PLAYER AND NOT THE MOST VALUABLE
TEAM.
>> BUT THE LEAGUE.
>> NO IT IS THE VALUE TO THE
TEAM.
>> STEPH CURRY IS THE BEST
PLAYER, STOP IT.
>> AND ALSO, YOU HAVE THE BEST
SEASON, DOES NOT MAKE YOU THE
BEST SEASON.
>> I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
LOBBYING HARD FOR CHRIS PAUL,
AND YOU ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT HE
IS NOT IN THE TOP THREE OR CAN
YOU SEE THAT?
>> WELL, THE WAY THAT STEPH IS
PLAYING, HE IS EDGING OUT CP3,
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE FOR WHAT
HE HAS DONE FOR PHOENIX, AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE CHRIS IN
THERE, BUT NO DOUBT IN MY MIND
THAT I AGREE WITH SHAQ, THE WAY
THAT STEPH CURRY HAS BEEN
PLAYING, BUT NOW, SHAQ, THEY ARE
NOT IN THE PLAYOFFS YET, SO HE
DOES NOT DESERVE THE MVP AND
JOKER IS GOING TO GET IT, AND
JOEL IS HURT BY INJURY, AND I
WOULD HAVE LOVED TO SEE CP3, BUT
NOBODY CAN TAKE AWAY WHAT STEPH
IS DOING.
>> AND THIS ONE, ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR.
>> THIS IS A TOUGH ONE.
>> SO MUCH TIME MISSED BY
CERTAIN PLAYERS AND TALKING
ABOUT THE ALL-NBA TEAMS, AND NOW
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR, IT IS LaMELO
BALL, ANTHONY EDWARDS OR TYRICE
HALIBURTON, AND THE TOP THREE
IN, AGAIN, NO PARTICULAR ORDER.
>> WHERE IS THE PLAYER FROM THE
KNICKS.
>> QUIGLEY, HE DID NOT MAKE THE
TOP THREE.
>> AND WHO IS THE --
>> WELL, HE IS HAVING A HECK OF
A YEAR.
>> HE IS.
>> AND THEY ARE WINNING.